yeah listen i've been with sam tripoli
i'm doing that conspiracy social club
it's so fun
which is everything's a conspiracy well
he thought of it but you like debunk it
i do well shop called me up and said i
got it
i got this idea yeah you're gonna
triple is gonna hit you with conspiracy
theories and you're gonna be debunked
the problem is it's it's when you're
arguing it's exhausting
hey we i love sam he's the only i want
people know
he's the only guy my idea for the show
you know a lot of comics like i just
can't right now with you guys can't
right now
sam's like i'll do it yeah i'm like your
hell yeah
he's the best and then i mean yeah and
so but but
the problem with sam is that if you go
but sam i can google that's not true he
goes google's [ __ ]
where do i go he used like duck.go
duckduckgo
what's that but every it's like a
conspiracy where they can't track your
[ __ ]
i guess but everything to sam's a
conspiracy like if you show up in m m's
like
you eat blue m m's yeah he's like you
don't know about those you're like
no he's like bush man
actually i haven't really but conspiracy
theorists
it what it comes down to is this i
believe most of the [ __ ] that goes on
is due to incompetence ambition
stupidity miscalculation okay right
and i don't think that anybody i don't
think anybody has enough power to
control all the strengths because there
are just too many competing interests
even within an
administration yeah but conspiracy
theorists believe
that people are way more organized than
than i do
correct i believe that people are number
one the people at the top are evil
yep they're all evil and and they're
really well organized
and they are interested mainly in
evil outcomes or at least control and
all of them and they all talk
that's what they think they all
communicate and i think it's like
society like a secret system yeah but
but to your point i i think the prompt
like conspiracy
theorists like they put they almost give
too much credit to the government stuff
because
they make mistakes man a lot they make a
ton of them look at cuomo
look at the miscalculations he was
saying miss kazakhstan you killed a lot
of people but it's like
yes i know i i don't think that was a
political you know that's not his agenda
no no because he didn't get recalled now
no he's [ __ ] he's super awesome you
know
who kept us shut down there's a recall
going on i know he's
popular they don't want them no yeah
there wasn't some big
plan to do all this they just at the
time they thought in their head that was
the right move everyone's like oh it's a
conspiracy there's something behind
everything yeah like especially i think
it's funner than the truth
like did you watch a lot more on netflix
we talked about this little cat the
the cecil hotel one yeah so have you
seen the video of that weird girl in the
hotel i thought she was obviously
mentally disturbed
she climbed down clearly and she died
but how much fun like obviously the the
the ceso hotel has a history people died
there guy who was he had that garbage
i know who lost his poor guy
there was a musician who he's like a
dark music i think marilyn manson times
ten yeah yeah he's really not as
talented he's really dark
uh like me dark no i mean like dark like
inside
he's mexican but he like but he talks
about death and killing like he seemed
like a
he's a guy who's like an artist yeah
he's not a and so he was at the hotel
a year prior a year prior and all the
conspiracy theorists like
he stayed there he was there the same
time so they bombard his page
everything he does really like you
[ __ ] you killed her and all this
stuff he's like holy [ __ ]
he's like dude i have passports i have
uh studio documentary i say
i was here when she was killed i was
there a year ago oh so they blamed it on
me it ruined his career
it doesn't do music because it sounds
better he got cyber bullied the truth
the conspiracy theory but even the cops
are like man i know like all these
conspiracies like but you're not
cops like there's information that we
can't leak you that we have right that
we know
a web sleuth yes web slew yeah
that's awesome they talk about you gotta
get a job yeah how do you get
paid and they talk to this youtuber
who's balls deep in the cesa hotel
and he's like you know for my
calculations like yeah well you're not a
detective dude and the cops said that
cop said
there are things we don't release for
the family's sake yeah we don't want to
tell you
like she had horrible mental issues and
her sister told the district
a lot of men yeah but for bipolar yeah
her sister goes she's had these
uh issues before these episodes where
she goes crazy thinks somebody's trying
to kill her and they're like oh that's
what was going on there because she
didn't have her medication
she's doing the [ __ ] in the in the in
the elevator and then she
thinks someone's trying to kill her try
to escape into the to the water [ __ ]
thing
and then goes inside there and died why
don't people listen to her family then
the problem is not funny
exactly that's not interesting but the
problem with with believing
in conspiracies like that or in the
in the fun thing is that you're missing
the actual threat
yeah you know the real threat we're
facing i think in this country
is this polarization between megaville
and wokeville
and and and you know the media makes a
lot of money
getting that keeping those divisions
keeping those two groups those two
villes
fighting and they're actually but
they're both extreme but i think the
majority of people are in the middle
yes they're in the level right so the
left on the right make the headlines and
left and right are on social media
and you can purify the rainbow chamber
99 of people are in the middle
yeah you know what's like like we're
watching i might be i might be a
democrat i might be republican
but i'm not them or i'm not there how
about this
i'm a republican i'm a democrat i'm a
centrist depending on the issue
give me
let me let me be responsive to the
evidence you know that's what i think is
the big worry
i really do but i think that the media
summer elements media are ideologically
aligned to the far left because of the
way they've been educated and you have
the reaction on the other side
yes and if you start playing identity
politics i don't want to break people
into groups
i don't like this talk i don't think it
makes any sense i i don't think it
serves
any it doesn't people into groups like
in prison yards yes
you you got to join the white aryans or
the black brotherhood or the [ __ ]
you have to survive if you're you want
to make the united states a [ __ ]
are we is the united states a [ __ ]
painting is this
if you want to study if you're not
obsessed with color go to art school i
don't want to talk about color
i want to talk about potential and
merits and and who's the best person for
the job
yeah excuse me i gotta run for prep oh i
can't
you thought about
[Applause]
how about governor i feel like you could
beat newsome
yeah i don't know hey you know what you
know what's so funny hey
[Music]
you look
and not 20 minutes go by i'm not called
a weathered world
a [ __ ] weathered world next to the
newsome pickles
he's only staying next to newsome he's
always saying next no no next facebook
makes me look like a turd with ice
he's such a good looking dude but bad
ryan weathered worm calendar
dude every time it comes with a nickname
i sell shirts
you can have those my podcast was
burn i call it big and hungry i saw that
dude
so i get this from brennan like i'm
excited steve's [ __ ] hilarious and
it's great
yeah and it drops every monday it's all
good but
uh monday on youtube and apple oh yeah
all over you place with an asian guy
replace your tube
he goes like this yeah whatever he goes
he's in i got a text from him
he always like he always like he goes
hey first of all your [ __ ] backdrop
what is this and second of all there's
nothing big and hungry about a skinny
asian guy and a skinny white guy what
the [ __ ] are you doing i'm like
i went like i was my girlfriend was
there and i went like this i go
she goes what's that i go nothing no i
was in a sour mood because you were kind
of right
yeah yeah i went brian are you big
or hungry because no i'm it's steve big
or hungriest
it's just not your wheelhouse it's not
your wheelhouse you have so many skills
when it comes to marketing it's like not
good but no bad at self-promotion
i know i gotta call you yeah but but
back to salmon conspiracies like
where it gets dicey is some conspiracies
i get and i'm in on yeah
like i'll talk to sam and uh and eddie
like via group tax and some of them
they'll tell you like hey i can i can
get with that like jfk 100 conspiracy
110
mafia induced and then september 11th
kind of edging on the conspiracy a
little bit there read
lawrence wright's book uh the looming
tower though uh he's
he does separate oh i mean there's a
there's a paper trail
there's a cia trail there's a defense
department defense trail there's an army
there's a trail to this there was a
there was a history of these suicide
bombs
bombers by a group called al-qaeda
al-qaeda which means the base in arabic
where's my camera right you know what i
mean so it it it
you gotta you gotta read those books and
you'll go again it's like
the cia didn't bomb the united states
but this is where i'm at with conspiracy
it's like
if i hear that's like all right i'll
read that yeah and it can change my mind
like i'm not like sam and eddie where
i'm like no [ __ ]
that guy's in on it that arthur's in him
like nah man all right
i'll read that but it is fun to believe
yeah especially with tower seven
i mean yeah somebody gets sticky yeah
yeah yeah again you know so osama had
the contract so what you don't think
but i've interviewed i've interviewed a
lot of full-time conspiracy theorists
like the guy who believes in flat earth
how now he's he's in his
he's my age and that's so sad does he
have kids
i believe so and then there was a guy
who's a chemtrail guy
and what's very interesting is that if
you're going to talk about chemtrails or
if you're going to talk about
flat earth yeah you might want to have a
background
in some kind of a scientific discipline
even engineering would be cool
whatever take whatever you got chemical
engineering give me anything whatever
geology how about astrophysics i'll take
it whatever i'll take if you took a
couple classes astrology
anything sure um and what i get is i go
now what's your educational background
and immediately go well if you're going
to ask me if i have a paper from some
[ __ ]
institution yeah okay so there we are
there you go so you've done your own you
are a web salute
they yeah start with this they all say
they all say i didn't i was i didn't
start as a conspiracy theorist i didn't
start
believing in this but i started looking
into it and then that means
you were educated by them and affirm
your bias yeah and it's fun
and it's fine but you get in the
comments you're on your heels though
you're on your heels once they go
i didn't get a [ __ ] degree from you
talking about the institutions like
you mean college dude no and then you're
just like all right well what happens
also though is if you have a guy who's a
full-time flat earther
yeah they have a lot of information yeah
they they're going to hit you with a
thousand things i
don't work on flat earth because don't
believe it yeah
yeah well because science and other
things and so
you're not a scientist so you're not
going to be able to kind of you're not
going to be able to mount some
defense when they say have you ever seen
a satellite with your own eyes have you
ever seen you know and you're like
i don't know but that's what about fight
patterns but that's what they do like
that's their thing so they're ready to
whatever you have they
they have it in the chat well i said
when so you're not if you're not ready
for the argument man
it looks like they know what they're
talking about but when you when i said
when you
when you chart a flight from here to
australia
you have to take into account the
curvature of the earth and he said yeah
but
a lot of pilots are speaking up about
this now because they're just being uh
huh so they're being sent on routes that
they're all that long i see so they're
all in on and also that
all that fuel haven't bee have you ever
seen the v i'm you should show us to sam
on your show there's a video of this
he's a big flat earther
and he's like uh he set a date he's like
i'm gonna prove it i'm gonna get up
before sunrise and he has this tool that
shows like
the earth he said it's gonna show it
just goes up and down and not like
and he's like with the curve yeah yeah
and it curves and you just hear them go
ah
[ __ ]
and the camera shuts off
[Laughter]
you can also set up lasers you can shoot
a laser through a hole if you if
everything
was flat you could you know yeah and you
know this guy this flat earther
nice guy i don't want to i don't want to
out these guys but but he but he uh it
apparently that the laser was oh tweet
oh yeah so sometimes
things get tweaked see i like i like
this uh use on world star it says flat
earth
gets a wake-up call that's a great
haircut
but i shouldn't have to talk about it
it's fun though right yeah
it was fun probably the first four
episodes well i love sam
sam and i just [ __ ] yeah because
he's not always sam sam tripoli is
a great comic legend he's [ __ ] you
know it's like steve too like
i did a so we did a live podcast in
nashville for big hungry
and and steve is on stage now steve's
been doing stand-up
for 25 years and when you see that
[ __ ]
improvise with an audience you know i
was watching him and i was like
this is you'll love this guy i look at
him and i look at him i'm like this
[ __ ] is so good
he's been doing this for 25 years so
he's got a bag of tricks
that is well it's bigger than santa's
back he can just pull out and just come
up with whatever
and then a guy named theo vaughn
came on in the last 15 minutes you guys
aren't ready for that smoke
smoke i mean that dude will come on and
just start saying crazy
[ __ ] and if he's on you're just like oh
i don't i don't have the same
wavelength that he's oh my god do king
of sink sometimes and
like you know a guest would do a
submission and he's just firing away i'm
like i just
my brain doesn't work like my god like
his crazy but it all makes sense yeah
and the references are so
yeah and but interesting and like out of
left field and you're like oh
he said to me i was talking like this
and i said yeah and he goes you sound
like a guy
in a who's coming out from behind a
curtain in a castle right now
he's just [ __ ] but it makes sense oh
god damn he's [ __ ] hilarious he's
great he
he uh moved to nashville about a house
we're looking at him he's looking at
yeah he's looking at property you know
um
because you were thinking about binaural
well you know there's nashville and
there's austin
i was in texas oh okay in a blizzard and
no power you know now a couple things
about texas i if you
texas is great now now come talk to me
and you know this
in june july and august and september
because if you think you know hot daddy
i'm well you're from arizona i'm in
arizona yeah he's from america
here's the difference dry dry texas gets
all kinds of humidity yeah houston i
can't [ __ ] with houston in the summer
you're walking through
probably you can't really even go out
like
it's different than vegas it's like it
you ruined your clothes
you feel bad for your shoes yeah like
the ground's so hot august in san
antonio
i th the woman sees me walking out of
the hotel and
she goes where are you going i go i'm
walking to starbucks and she said
starbucks is almost half a mile away i
said yeah she goes you're not walking
the starbucks
and i go i am she goes oh it's too hot
hun
and i go i am i've lived in saudi arabia
i took about 10 steps
right [ __ ] by the center of the sun
what the [ __ ] is going on but and then i
got hit by locusts yeah
oh but the thing is like
last summer in woodland hills we reached
one like
116 yeah 115 and it's like hot
dude yeah like you came like even the
pool is not comfortable
oh yeah like walking to the pool you
your third degree burns
your sandals it's just like i'm just
staying soft yeah
it's too hot to swim yeah i can deal
with hot i can't deal with humidity
though yeah that's like florida
yeah dry santa dry heat all day for me
dry heat i can take dry heat
yeah the humidity i was down in miami
and from my hotel room i watched a shark
swim you're lying you know what you're
one of them no way and i'm fine with it
no no you know what that was all it is
[Applause]
i know i'm too long
you're going to think i'm lying and i
would be lying and i'm alive however
the mountain lion light are you and
rogan oh that was the greatest yeah
dude i see like i see all sorts of yeah
i see but they were i wasn't getting the
reaction i needed out of them
coyotes rattlesnakes and then they're
like cool
i see mountain lions mountain lions all
the time and i go like this i stop and i
go
talking to me
they're around there though
yeah so you saw a shark do you mind yeah
no
i'm in my i'm in my balcony and i looked
down and we saw
i'm still a manatee first a manatee
and even that's in that stuff sea cows
yes
shadow and it was coming and i was like
get out of the water
from your balcony did he look up no
because i was
i was on floor 36 but
i saw a shadow coming up i had to prove
[ __ ] to you guys
and then the shadow was like this and i
was like out
and then the shadow didn't change
direction
all right guys i'll see you later
what's up how about that when i get off
stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son